pas bon
bon
bon bon
je vous propose maintenant l'écouté un
citoyen de lac-mégantic yvon rosa vous
allez voir qu'il l'a échappé belle ce
matin on peut parler d'huile
certainement comme un miraculé il a dû
courir pour fuir les flammes et s'est
jeté dans l'eau notre journaliste mary
ellen brosseau a recueilli son
témoignage est remplie d'émotions on
devine boule de feu tomber sur bordeaux
nous donnons des rendu d'un loup fait
qu'un autre abaissement est parti à
courir pour aller vers chez moi au condo
pour prendre le bateau pour son parti
cible ces douaniers au dessus du au
dessus de l'option ça n'est vraiment
plus que çà çà çà çà analystes a cité
cinq ans est infernal
puis l'inquiétude quant à savoir les
gens qui concerne la vie de beaucoup de
l'ocs appartement savoir les enfants les
jeunes les paroles et les autorités ont
eu ce qu'a fait savoir
c'est pourquoi on avait pris un verre
avec eux les lélés les gens qui
travaillent qui travaille ça c'est
l'inquiétude congo notamment
e
mais on sortait d'une musique a fait et
on faisait face carrément au train qui
qui est en train de perdre le contrôle
et puis on a vu que ça allait dérailler
donc ils vont me dit on sauve le c'est
dangereux on va se faire écraser par le
train mais sauf que c'était peau selon
sky est des rails il a sauté cette
affaire lui le fait que tu prends tes
jean mathon coopi sauve la sauvetat
poule semaine en sauver d'autres mais
est pas capable de revenir en arrière
faute avant sous la bare on y pense
beaucoup au cje andorre
de beaucoup d'amis déchets seront voyais
souvent
mais qui garde et on n'aura pas voulu ça
pour eux on était plus cher sur le dot
gade h taleo finira
des enfers madame la fontaine me
souviens que mais la fontaine m'a pris
dans ses baux décomptée swallow nous
autres le père d'une autre crise mais on
est on est contente toi de swallow c'est
c'est toucher à quelque chose que ce
soit à réaliser du roi c'est vrai que
c'est peut-être moi qui l'a peut être
loupé nui à ma place d'où en outre
attachée depuis lac-mégantic c'est des
gens qui se situent monfils tient ça
aurait été une ville différente qu'on
connaît pour ses con con con c'est pour
l'envergure où l'air qu'est ce qui va se
passer dans le futur au lac mégantic
mais je pense que ça va être quelque
chose de intéressant pour le futur des
jeunes ce qui va se passer ici ses
demandes en mariage pour célébrer cet
été le dauphin ou sur le bord du lac
au lac mercier whiplash miracle surtout
way